(ominous music)
- Sami Thicket, huh?
That's quite a journey.
- There you are.
I was afraid you got lost.
(soft music)
(gasps)
- I've read all about you.
(soft music)
- Because the sanction are true chosen.
- Let's have an adventure, Gurjin.
It'll be great fun, Gurjin,
but it never is.
- The bonds of sisterhood can be tested,
but never broken.
- It's mother's fault.
She spoils her, Brea's her favorite.
(soft music)
- Honored lords,
welcome to Ha'rar.
- To the crystal.
- But I see the chance
for a new beginning.
- May the dead become one with Thra again.
May we feel their tears in rain.
(soft music)
- Here's the rest of the
materials you requested, Princess.
- Is there a problem?
- It's your son, Rian.
- Oh.
- Your return to Stone in the Wood
puts our clan in a dangerous position.
- If I come out of this crazy,
the last thing I'll do
before I lose my mind
is take your life.
- Perhaps we should all
take a deep calming breath.
- Old friend, why make me walk so far?
- We are eternal.
- I will not fail you.
- I deserve to be punished.
Flog me.
Scold me.
- We must make a bloody example
of this treacherous Gelfling.
- Oh, why am I not surprised?
- Guess we'll get the crystal.
- Only the hunt matters.
- Oh it's wonderful to see you.
Do you see my wonder?
Look upon my wonder.
- One.
Did the message find them?
- You turned your eye away from Thra.
What's the stars?
- Another world.
Another time.
Another age.
- [Woman] Who catches the light?
Splitting the darkness.
Revealing your destiny.
- [Deet] I don't think
anything will ever be
like it was again.
- [Rian] No, it will be better.